[Music]
doesn't it seem that lately a lot of
movies have been shot in London one
example is Bridget Jones's baby a movie
from the bridget jones's Sarko which i
might have seen just look at the
skyscrapers in the background of that
movie
those were simply not there in the first
movie of the saga
in fact London skyline has changed
dramatically in the last 10 years alone
and this is pretty surprising because
we're not talking about an emerging
economy here like China or Singapore
[Music]
actually the overall economy in the UK
has not performs that well over the last
few years however London is another
world entirely today it is one of the
four fastest growing capitols on the
planet almost growing at the same level
as Dubai their population has increased
by 50% in the last two decades
[Music]
this is particularly odd on a continent
like Europe where all countries are
seeing overall population decline
instead London has three million more
inhabitants and not only that but in the
finance world London is now more
importance than New York City itself so
now you might be wondering what exactly
has happened in London that has caused
this massive success well that's the
question we're going to be answering in
today's visual politic video immigration
the United Kingdom has always been a
country of immigrants and London was
always the main destination nonetheless
in the last decade emigration has
absolutely skyrocketed after Poland's
became a member of the European Union in
2004 a lot of poles easily moved from
Poland to London because there was no
visa required
[Music]
the same happened when Bulgaria and
Romania became part of the European
Union in 2007 this created a whole new
influx of immigrants adding to those
already they're from India and Pakistan
these European immigrants typically have
a higher education and university
degrees in fact today London has 1.7
million highly-skilled workers while New
York has 1.6 million immigrants are not
only working the jobs that British
people don't want to do anymore instead
they are coming to the country and
starting their own businesses or getting
hired in the high-tech sector but Tom
started his marketing business four
years after arriving from Warsaw he now
employs six people and four of them are
British
butts companies are far more than just
job-creating machines or economic growth
engines the fact that London has more
educated people means more bars more
exhibitions more culture in summary it
has more of all the things that make a
city look cool for example well where's
the best-known Peruvian restaurant
outside of Peru
well according to all of the
gastronomical guides it's a restaurant
called ceviche which of course is
located in London
[Music]
and this is how London has created a
virtuous circle that has attracted more
and more people this is why in 2008
after the financial crisis hit many
Spaniards Portuguese and Italians who
wanted to leave their countries saw
London as the main destination it was
more than just a good place to find a
job it was a cool place to live this is
something that economists call the
network effect the more people and
companies that you have the easier it is
to attract highly skilled immigrants
today a new generation of coders bankers
and financial tech wizards are remaking
this extraordinary place interestingly
since 2010 over 1,000 startups have been
created in London every single year but
hold on a moment
because there's more the city of London
all the skyscrapers that you see here
are concentrated in a single area this
is an area not bigger than a square mile
and it is known as the City of London or
just of the city yes on the one hand we
do have London and then also on the
other hand we have the city of London
the City of London essentially works
like its own country within the United
Kingdom yes now we normally say that
Britain is made up of four nations
England Wales Scotland in Northern
Ireland but really this is not exactly
true in fact we should really add a
fifth one and this is the City of London
the city has its own laws and has its
own mayor the city is the financial
center of Great Britain about 7,000
people live in the city but each day
300,000 come to work in its banks
brokerage firms and insurance companies
London's mayor is the man was showing on
the screen now
his name is Sadiq Khan but the City of
London has its own Lord Mayor and his
name is Jeffrey Monta vans one of the
characteristics over the city also known
as the square mile is that during
elections both citizens and companies
have the right to vote for example
Unilever has its headquarters in the
square mile therefore when elections
come Unilever
is allowed to vote in
so now you might be wondering does
Unilever get the same voting power as a
smaller company well the answer is no is
the number of votes a company gets
depends on how many people they employ
in the city
by the way the music that is
accompanying this video that you were
listening to right now is by a bands
called The Forgotten voice they're a pop
rock band from Island who sent us their
music to use in this video and if you
liked it and you would like to hear more
from them and please do check out the
links in the description of the live
[Music]
all right so now you might be wondering
whether the City of London is a fiscal
haven and the answer is no all across
the UK taxes are fairly similar but what
is true is that the square-mile does
have more business-friendly policies
than the rest of the UK for instance
their urban development laws are much
more free and open than the rest of the
country and this is why there are more
skyscrapers but when it comes to taxes
they are not a haven whatsoever let's
hold on just a minute because the city
does play a really important role this
is because the main task of the Lord
Mayor is to travel all around the world
and promote London as a great place for
doing business the Lord Mayor of the
City of London
alderman Alan yarrow is to lead a
business delegation to Indonesia helping
to make sure London and the UK remained
the original partner of choice when it
comes to financial and professional
services
so in a way you could say that London
has its own marketing department
showcasing all of the benefits of doing
business there to the rest of the world
business concentration the US economy is
divided among different cities for
example politics is centered in
Washington DC finances in New York City
Entertainment is in Los Angeles and
technology is centered in San Francisco
the same happens in Germany where you
have cities like Berlin Frankfurt and
Munich and over in Spain you have
Barcelona and Madrid on the other hand
Britain has London and well just London
the other large cities are far less
important to the country's economy in
fact London generates every one in five
pounds in the British economy in this
city you will find all of the major
government institutions the banks the
technological centre the fashion centre
etc
[Music]
while the amount of tax generated in
London increased by 25% in real terms
between 2005 and 2015
Manchester's tax intake grew by only 1%
while Birmingham Glasgow and Leeds also
significant decreases in their tax
intake and to all of this we should add
another really important element and
that's English as you probably know the
UK has had a rather good relationship
with the United States well at least for
the past two centuries even though there
is no trade agreements between the two
countries they do have a lot of history
in common and importantly they speak the
same language add to this the fact that
the United Kingdom is currently a part
of the European Union and you can see
why London has become the gateway for
American companies who want to do
business in Europe what London does it
is the capital of the euro and that
means that 70% of forex trading and all
sorts of other over-the-counter
derivatives all sorts of fancy stuff
gets done through London although the UK
is not in the euro so there's a very
difficult set of negotiations coming up
[Music]
but now the obvious and big question is
going to be how is brexit going to
affect London's growth one thing is very
clear and that's that while the majority
of the British population wanted the UK
to leave the European Union London was
very much remained
so these are our thoughts here at visual
politic and we would love to know your
so use the comment section below to let
us know what you think and don't forget
to thumbs up this video and subscribe
because we put our brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday and as
always if you'd like to dig deeper into
this topic please do check out the links
in the description below and I'll see
you next time